محامي دون اتعاب مبادره جديده كشفت عنها
الهيئه السعوديه للمحامين تتضمن توكيل
محامي لكل مستفيد من الضمان الاجتماعي
يصعب عليه دفع الاتعاب في مرافعاته
القضائيه هناك عدد من
المندرجين في طلبات الحصول على المعونه
القضائيه
من قبل هي السعوديه للمحامين وايضا
يتم ايصال هذه المحامين
الراغبين في تقديم هذه المعونه القضائيه
للمستحقين
المامول من هذه الاتفاقيه باذن الله تعالى
انها ترفع مستوى
التعاون ما بين الجانبين بحيث انه تصل
لاكبر شريحه ممكنه من المستحقين المبادره
اطلقت قبل ايام وانضم اليها اكثر من 300
محام سعودي ابدوا استعدادهم للترافع عن
المسجلين في الضمان الاجتماعي بالتعاون
وزاره الموارد البشريه والتنميه
الاجتماعيه التي عملت على تطوير منصه
الكترونيه لاستقبال الطلبات مع جهود اخرى
لاعلام مستفيدي الضمان عبر فروع الوزاره
بالمدن والقرى السعوديه
الغرض انه كثير من المحامين يعبر دائما عن
رغبتهم في الدعم
المجتمع من خلال تقديم ساعات عمل مجانيه
او الترافع بشكل مجاني
واعتقد الجهه الامثل لتقدم لهذه الساعات
التطوعيه ويترافع بشكل مجاني اخواننا
وزملائنا ومن المستحقين
الضمان الاجتماعي خدمه المحامي المجاني
تعبر عن الدور الاجتماعي الذي يقدمه
المحامون المتطوعون وتعد من ابرز
التحديثات التي يشهدها القطاع العدلي في
السعوديه بين عام
اخر من الرياض نواف عزيز العربيه
انضم الينا المتحدث باسم وزاره الموارد
البشريه والتنميه الاجتماعيه سعاده الحماد
حياك الله سعد سعيد
منها وكيف يتم ذلك
حياك الله اخوي خالد وحيا الله كافه
السيدات والساده المشاهدين والمستمعين
الكرام طبعا هذه الخدمه باختصار شديد هي
مقدمه لمستفيدين الضمان الاجتماعي اللي لا
يتمكنون او لا يستطيعون من دفع اتعاب
المحاماه للاستعانه بمحامي امام مختلف
كافه الجهات القضائيه وبالتالي نعمل على
دعم هؤلاء المستفيدين وفق استراتيجيه
مدروسه لضمان حياه كريمه لهم وتحقق
استقرار هؤلاء المستفيدين وايضا بالتعاون
مع الهيئه السعوديه للمحامين نقوم برفع
مستوى ممارسه المحامين لمهنتهم وضمان حسن
ادائهم فيما يقدمونه لكافه
مستفيدين وكافه ايضا الجوانب الخاصه
بالقضاء الخدمات طبعا المقدمه نتكلم اليوم
عن استشارات فيما يخص فيما يخص الجوانب
القضائيه ونتحدث عنها ايضا المساعده في
اعداد
الصياغه او الخاصه باللوائح القانونيه
والترافع امام الجهات القضائيه طبعا
المستفيدين هم كافه المستفيدين الضمان
الاجتماعي بدون تحديد فئات معينه او تحديد
يعني مستويات معينه من ناحيه المستفيدين
من الضمان الاجتماعي بس هذه المبادره
والمنصه فقط للمستفيدين الضمان الاجتماعي
طبعا خليني بس اذكر نقطه مهمه هي ليست
منصه حديثه اللحظه هي خدمه موجوده على
الهيئه السعوديه للمحامين وهي خدمه
المعونه القضائيه ولكن اليوم حنا من خلال
توقيع هذه الاتفاقيه تم اطلاق باسم خدمه
المعونه القضائيه المستفيدين الضمان
الاجتماعي ولا اصلا الخدمه هي موجوده
بالسابق لكافه المواطنين في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه اليوم حنا نتكلم عن انه
المستفيد من الضمان الاجتماعي بامكان
الدخول على هذه الخدمه من خلال تسجيله في
الموقع وبعد ذلك يضع الجوانب التي تتعلق
بطلب المحامي وايضا يقوم تاكيد لانه
مستفيد من الضمان الاجتماعي يرفق مشهد
ضمان اجتماعي في خانه تحميل او تعريف
الراتب وبعد ذلك يكمل باقي التسجيل هنا
يتم اعفاء المستفيد الضمان الضمان
الاجتماعي من مساله اتعاب المحامي وايضا
هناك امتداد سابق لقرار سامي باعفاء
مستفيدين الضمان الاجتماعي من ناحيه
تكاليف الاحكام القضائيه ونقصد في ذلك
الجوانب التي اقرت اقرت على مرافعات
وتحصلها الجهه المعنيه في هذا الامر
فاليوم الوزاره تعمل على كافه الجوانب
التي تتعلق بالجوانب في كل القضايا ساعد
ولا في قضايا معينه في كافه الجوانب نتكلم
عن استشارات قانونيه في قضايا الطلاق
والحضانه والنفقه وايضا نتكلم عن جوانب
خاصه بالاحوال الشخصيه نتكلم عن جوانب
خاصه ايضا متابعه الجوانب العماليه وايضا
متابعه حال المستفيدين وغيره من الجوانب
المتعلقه عده مسارات طيب الخطوات اللي تتم
ما يسجل في المنصه ويرفق المشهد وغيرها من
الامور وش الخطوات التاليه بعد ذلك عارضه
مباشره يتم تواصل المحامي المعني المتطوع
في هذا الامر وبالتالي يقوم بدراسه حاله
حيثيه المستفيد من الضمان الاجتماعي وقم
بالترفع عن الحاله مباشره عندنا عده
مسارات ويخلف في هذا الموضوع مسارين
المسار الاول كيف يتم التقديم خاصه من
اشخاص كبار في السن او اشخاص ذوي الاعاقه
لا يستطيعون الوصولون او الوصول الى هذه
الخدمه هنا لدينا عيادات التمكين الموجوده
في كافه مناطق المملكه بامكان كبير السن
او الاشخاص ذوي الاعاقه زياره
هذه الحضانه وبالتالي شرح او العياده شرح
الموضوع وشرح حيثياته يقومون به تقديم
مسار سريع له وخدمه بشكل مطلوع المطلوب
ايضا لدينا مسار خاص
بالباحث الاجتماعي الذي يقوم بزياره
المستفيدين من الضمان في منازلهم والتاكد
من حالتهم الصحيه وحالتهم الاجتماعيه وغير
من الجوانب وفي حال شعر بانه يحتاج الى
محاور محامي يقوم بالتقديم بالمسار السريع
لهذا المستفيد من الضمان الاجتماعي خدمناه
بشكل سريع هنا وايضا مستفيده اخرين
بامكانهم الدخول على الخدمه بشكل مباشر
وطلب كافه التفاصيل المهنيه في هذا عندكم
احصائيه وارقام بعدد الاستفاده من هذه
المبادره والمنصه حتى الان ولا يعني
مبدئيا ولله الحمد حتى الان يعني من خلال
هذه الاتفاقيه استفد اكثر من 500 شخص وهذا
امر يؤكد على اهميه مثل هذه الاتفاقيات
التي عملت عليها الوزاره سواء مع الهيئه
السعوديه للمحامين او سواء مع القطاع
الخاص او سواء مع القطاع غير ربحي في
الجوانب القانونيه او الاجتماعيه او
التعليم
تماما ولا رمزي
لا مجاني لا محامي هو متطوع صحيح طيب انا
نشكرك وبالتالي بعدها يكون هذا المحامي
ملتزم معه في المرافعه وفي القضايا وفي
غيرها من الامور ولا فقط يقتصر دوره على
تقديم الاستشاره لا يتصل دوره في
مطالبه حقوق المستفيد وغيرها من الجوانب
المتعلقه بالاستشارات الفنيه وغيرها من
الصياغه وغيرها جزاهم الله خير المحامين
المتطوعين وان شاء الله نقرا يعني كمان
عدد اكبر من العدد الحالي لينضموا لها